we uh
we both used to record at mall Studio
yeah at his house yeah when you know
before all that other stuff happened so
that was a crazy house to be at yeah it
was it was one of the more legendary
places I frequented in my life yeah it's
crazy too because if you think back to
like Prime like
you know I remember taking like two
chains over there for the first time in
like 2010 like uh that's a big Sean over
there Franny was bringing everyone and
their mom over there Mall's crib was
insane it was like uh
it was it was I think it was crazier
than people even like hear about because
I feel like once he got on TV and things
kind of
spun in that direction you know the
Mystique was kind of gone but yeah for a
while yeah that's that's 100 right like
you said that you would come to Vegas
and you'd be like who is this guy I
think a lot of people still ask me about
him yeah to this day people still be
like you know matter of fact I just had
somebody ask me about him about 30
minutes ago I was just in the jury
District before I came here today what's
up with Molly Morgan somebody said that
yeah that was someone I don't really
speak on his situation too much I was
just like I don't [__] with him no more
yeah it's a situation that you know if
if it's a you know it is what it is but
yeah but what was what was the crib like
though back then when you were recording
because he had this house he had a man
that was a that was a dog run with a
bunch of wolves I gave him a wolf one of
them was mine man the [__] wolves I
remember I went to a Pettit and the
thing I almost took my hand one of them
one of the moves was mine I couldn't
keep it at my house so I gave it to him
he had a [__] bullet like giant snake
in the garage she had the the back house
which was like two or three Studios yeah
I mean that's where the model was a lot
he let me um he used to let me record
for free yeah
as long as it wasn't booked and then um
it was a it was a that that house you
never heard her know at that house from
the female I think once they got there
it was just everything was you know it's
like this is the agreement yeah like you
know what I'm saying I think that's why
Justin Bieber enjoyed it so much as a
child yeah for sure for sure
yo I was I don't know were you there he
had a birthday party
with Justin Bieber was there whiz Chris
Brown I wouldn't know I didn't make that
oh my God I just remember Justin Bieber
was clearly high on something that
wasn't marijuana and it was just a bunch
of naked [__] serving drinks and had
there was the weed bar with like the
word arcade machines it was a wild house
man legendary [__] yeah super yeah yeah
look I don't know all the details of his
circumstance but you know we had some
good times with Molly ball man